what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 15th of december the
halftime mark is [__] here the joint
is brought to you by
manscape it's time to pull your
chestnuts out of the fire and give them
a little [__] polish [__] it's
christmas time if this don't make you
want to shave your nut sack i don't know
what does and i'm here with manscape to
prevent cuts to make your dick look like
the [__] mona lisa it all starts with
the performance package 4.0 and the
lawnmower body trimmer the best trimmer
on the market for your balls your
muffler and your body order today
and i'll throw in the [__] weed
whacker a nose and ear hair trimmer that
helps prevent knicks snags and tugs in
those holes but wait there's more i'm
going to give you the crop preserver
which i have on today ball deodorant
tremendous and crop reviver just takes
the wrinkles out of your nut sack you
may look like you're 60 but your balls
look like you're [__] 20. plus the
anti-shaving boxes from manscape and
they also throw in a [__] travel bag
listen there's a thousand people who
could you you ever look at somebody and
go to his ass in the smell
i wonder what that ass smells like when
you look at your uncles and [__]
do you know what that ball sack must
smell like manscaped is the gift you're
looking for and now you compare that
with
the aloe vera and sea salt body wash
just in time for the holidays it's a
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner the
whole package works from your head to
your [__] jingle ball sack that's why
they call the perfect [__] package
your balls will shine
so bright your embarrassed [__]
rudolph you understand me and what we're
gonna do is this manscaped is giving you
20 off this is a gift for people right
now by [__] 10 of them if you give
them to all your uncles grandpa your dad
even your grandma look at her [__]
take a look at her tell me how bush
don't need to be shaved it probably
looks like a [__] spiderweb with all
that [__] white hair down there [__]
it these are presents it's jingle bell
time 20 off free worldwide shipping at
manscape.com
joey again you heard me right that's 20
off and free worldwide shipping at
manscape.com
joey be the ballsiest gift giver this
year with [__] manscape the
joint is also brought to you by cbd lion
tommy you don't know people who need a
[__] couple cbd [__] gummy bears
you do so what the [__] are you waiting
for you don't know what i'm talking
about i've been [__] talking about
cbd lion for three years now they helped
me through a surgery i'm a [__] old
man that works out i put the tape on the
cream is for my [__] knee the cream
is for my foot listen if you need cbd
cbd lionel [__] is the
they'll get it into your body with the
smoke they got the sour space candy kush
that you could [__] smoke you know
it's a pre-roll they got the cream they
got the tape they got the bath balls
enough cbd line is what you're looking
for start the new year off with a nice
1500 milligram tinction at cbd lion go
to cbdlion.com
and read the third-party lab results so
make your [__] eyeballs stick out of
your [__] head
start the year off tremendously feeling
better looking better with a better
outlook cbd lion is for you preston joey
or church or joint and get 20 off
delivered right to your [__]
house all right and the joint is also
brought to you by stamps.com listen
going to the post office this time of
the years are [__] stupid i'm looking
at my wife all she does is call the post
office and they come in and pick up the
gifts that she sends to tennessee and
whatever why would you wait in these
long lines
with these miserable stinky people when
stamps.com can help you with everything
from home you know how [__]
greatstamps.com is it makes my wife's
job a lot easier whether sending gifts
t-shirts mugs they bring the services to
the us postal service and ups right to
your [__] house you could print an
official postage from any letter package
or any way you want to ship
going to the post office instead of
using stamps.com it's like taking the
stairs when the elevator is right there
why the [__] would you do it with
stamps.com you get exclusive discounts
and postage from shipping from usps and
ups once your mail is ready just
schedule a pickup or drop it off no more
traffic no more lines take the confusion
out of shipping if you're not with
stamps.com you're slipping so do me a
favor sign up for the promo code joey
joey joey is the promo code for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
listen whether you have a small large
business stamps.com is for you i've been
using them for 10 [__] years so go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the the page
and enter code joey j-o-e-y you're going
to [__] hit me up and say joey you're
a genius stamps.com
never ever go to the post office again
let's get this party started on a
wednesday morning
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here it's wednesday the 15th
of [__] december it's a
beautiful day to be alive i'm feeling
great looking great smelling great balls
are in shape i put a little manscape
[__] reviver on my nut sack it's nice
and [__] smooth just getting ready
for a goddamn wednesday there's not much
going on like i said we have a guest
today but i want a [__] with you
guys
real fast yesterday i posted a picture
from 1983
on twitter and on [__] pay uh not
patreon but uh
whatever the [__] the one with the eye
who gives a [__]
instagram right and uh it was really
funny what happened was i had a meeting
monday i had a call a conference call
with the publishers of the book and
they're like hey man
we're looking for some [__] pictures
and i'm like you know what i didn't
think of any pictures because i'm too
busy writing the [__] book you know
then they tell me the book we're going
to hand it all in march 22nd and i go
when is the book going to be out ready
to go i was hoping they were saying
november like a thanksgiving christmas
release we could [__] around maybe do a
couple [__] appearances and [__]
they're like talking about may
of
2023 i'm like
so why the [__] are you bothering me
about that
do you have any idea of the cover not
even close i'm too busy writing a
[__] book
you know i got ideas for you but i'm not
even thinking about them right now it
was just a weird but that's the way it
is with these people like it was seven
college
women you know it was like five women
and two guys in the room
and they're like you know well what what
are you playing you know and they're
trying to show me how swarmy they are
and i'm like let's stop this right now
because this ain't gonna happen every
two weeks i thought we were gonna talk
about the [__] chapters
like you wanted more material on this or
something like that they're talking
about a [__] cover i mean are you
[__] [__] i'm
you know that's that's what people in
l.a do
don't have well for my cover i'm going
to do this is the book finished yet no
then what the [__] you worried about the
cover for you're putting a horse before
the [__] carriage you're getting
[__] or the carriage before the
horse i'm not sure what the [__] but
anyway
so i called my niece and i said listen
because she showed me some pictures one
time my niece had some [__] great
pictures
and i go where did you get them from
because my mom had them my mom passed
away and then she found them
and what happened was i used to write
them letters i liked uh
this was my brother mike and his wife so
you know he was all i had so i would
write them letters just to keep them i
loved writing letters i always loved
writing letters so i would write letters
and uh
to keep in touch with my you know i was
such a mess
in [__] new jersey when i'd send them
those pictures just to
just to show them that i had grown a
little bit you know that i wasn't still
a [__] mess
and if you look at those pictures like i
posted one in the morning and then i
posted another one with me with a hat on
walking in the woods
it's because the caption to it is
[__] you guys thought that i couldn't
bury somebody that i don't know how to
bury people in the woods that's my uh
listen if you lived in colorado and
you're half a hustler you bumped into
people that's what they do for a living
they just bury [__] bodies for people
that up there there's not even enough
bodies you could tie some remember like
some guy put is that you where you used
to me that that was that was snowmass
village those pictures i wasn't even in
boulder yet they're all bouldery
pictures but when i look at that picture
of me standing there with the white
sweatshirt by myself with the charles
bronson hat on
i see a [__] happy guy you know i was
thinking about that picture before i put
it up i was looking at it i'm like
i was probably 20.
the picture i posted the first one of me
with the white sweatshirt on i was
probably 20.
i was
going to school at night
uh taking classes at colorado mountain
college
i was working for an electrician you
know
i was living a simple [__] life i was
making a little bit of money i was just
proud to be out there on my own you know
i had never seen
anywhere but like florida and [__]
l.a this is the first time i was ever
like in the mountains or anything
and i look at that picture and i look so
[__] happy in those pictures it's
just uh
i wish i would have looked at those
pictures a little closely before i went
back to new york in 84
and i ended up homeless and stuff that's
what i was talking about when i looked
at those pictures last night
that that was right before that disaster
i put as a joke pre-kidnapping
you know which is my timeline
everything's gonna be before the
kidnapping and after the kidnapping
these are the pictures
before the kidnapping it's like after
christ died and before christ died
so we'll put like uh after k and bk so
be ak
after the kidnapping bk before the
[__] kitten happened
but i look at those pictures and i see a
[__] happy
you know
i had just had like four years
of [__] horrible luck
nothing was working out for me and i
bumped into a friend of mine and he's
like hey man i'm going to colorado
i didn't know if i was going to stay but
i just wanted to get out get the [__]
out of here
to give my mind to breathing you know i
was telling mike before that
the breather that we all got during the
pandemic was well needed like the i
always find the silver lining and the
silver lining
to the pandemic i found was
my new search for happiness like
this was all [__] with the life we
were living before
the pandemic and that's why so many
people are quitting their jobs that's
why so many people are switching careers
because a lot of people got to take a
break and look around them and see what
the [__] was going on with their lives
you know what they didn't like and it
gives you a chance to [__] clean up
or
keep being the [__] the sack of [__]
that you are like i was you know before
i came here
and i made adjustments to my life i feel
a lot better i look a lot better i'm
thinking a lot clearer
and that's the most important thing that
sometimes with everything going on you
don't get a chance to think clearly you
know i was the one guy that was always
against vacations i mean
what put me on the map as a stand-up was
i didn't take vacations there was no
[__] one day off no two days off i
worked seven days a week for [__] 20
years i didn't give a [__] about sundays
i didn't give a [__] about christmas i
didn't give a [__] about the holidays i
didn't give a [__] about anybody and
that attitude was appropriate for the
time when i was there doing it i had
nothing i had no family there now it's a
different time i've grown into a family
you know i'm having a great time with
them i have a life now and
yeah you know i don't know if i'll go
back to my whole life
but i'm enjoying my new [__] life i
enjoy doing this i enjoy working out i
enjoy having peace of mind i enjoy my
sad ladies with my daughter it's been a
a real [__]
education for me that's why i know 2022
is going to be great because i'm
launching off a great [__]
mindset you know your mindset has to be
right you ever talk to people you go
when was the last time you did acid or
whatever they'll say well
i had a bad trip guess what i've never
really had a bad trip
because the mindset
was always there you know
so always remember that if you're
struggling or having a tough time just
disconnect for a few days there's
nothing wrong with it as you learn
during the pandemic nothing wrong with
disconnecting unplug the [__] twitter
unplug the social media and just give
you a chance give yourself a chance to
[__] think nothing wrong with that
it's not a crime nobody's gonna throw
you in jail i owe you know the other
night i was watching uh
san francisco against buffalo i don't
know what night they played sunday night
you know and i'm like [__]
five years ago i was giving lee [__] for
watching a [__] football game
you know like listen i'm not sitting
there all day watching football games
but i'll watch two quarters of a game on
sunday at jimmy florentines then i'll
leave before go do a bunch of [__] and
then i'll go back and watch unlike
monday night i went over to jimmy's and
watch halftime i watch football till
halftime i can't sit there and watch a
whole [__] game
but you know what i was thinking about
how hypocritical i was well i wasn't
watching any games then
i'm watching games now like how
hypocritical i was of watching football
games but i'm not
i'm not in that search of getting
anything anymore i'm just in a search to
be healthy and to give you guys a good
podcast every week that's it those are
my responsibilities and to be a father
and to be a good husband i've wrapped it
up into four
simple things i got to be there for them
and i got to be there for you
[__] and i enjoy that i'm i'm
ready for you [__] today we got
a guest one of my best buddies i love
this kid
with all my heart we've had
disagreements but like i said on the
patreon podcast
every
like we've had two or three
disagreements but our relationship has
been stronger from them and that's how
you could tell
you have a good friend when you guys uh
have a problem because good friends have
problems from time to time
and then they resolve it and that
friendship gets stronger the guy i'm
talking about is [__] red band i love
with all my art
um if it wasn't for him we wouldn't even
be doing a podcast myself joe
all of us are very grateful to him
you know i i've always kept in touch
with red band since he's been in austin
and when lee said that on this podcast i
was like [__] i've never thanked redman
for that so i called him up like a man
i'm like hey buddy i just want to thank
you for creating this whole [__]
thing amongst us he was the one that got
joanne to podcast
he got hari to podcast me to podcast and
i'm very grateful to him so
the respects he is the original [__]
podfather so
what however you look at it i don't give
a [__] whatever you think of him i don't
give a [__] he's my brother he's a funny
dude and i love him with all my heart
enjoy red band
[Music]
welcome to the joint what's happening my
brother looking good
thanks buddy just woke up your [__]
crib
yeah i'm actually i'm not in my regular
studio i'm i'm in my uh vr studio right
now because i don't use zoom ever so
it's like i have to find a computer that
works on zoom so
it happens my friend it [__] happens
how you doing
good how'd it go last night
oh it was great man it was it was a lot
of fun uh
a lot of fun last night that show's
gotten out of control
really
yeah
you know after we spoke last time i
thought about your little operation down
there we were talking about how
it's really changed comedy because now
i mean i heard people are dumping agents
people are starting to dump agents
because they're saying [__] it
we can book our rooms ourselves we don't
need this aggravation it's becoming a
one-man operation now
and look at you you don't travel no more
and you're not even interested in
traveling you got your two nights
you got your i didn't even know that you
did your show and then you went back
into the podcast to keep the party alive
that's [__] brilliant
yeah i drive home i drive home and uh
there's so many fans that want to talk
about the show and stuff so i i i come
home and i
pretty much do this and i just talk to
the fans do virtual reality with them
and stuff
what time do you stay up to with them
uh last night it was up to about
3am i'd say holy [__] yeah
and it must be fun you know it's got to
be [__] fun to
just [__] with people till three in
the morning i'm [__] sleeping at 12
so
i would love to [__] with somebody
but you're gonna [__] with a [__]
guy with a sleep apnea mask on that's
all you guess
well now more than ever ever since covet
i i i really appreciate being home more
so uh
like being home is way better for me
where like when we lived in los angeles
it was always like i i can't be home i
have to i have to be at the comedy store
i have to be some i have to be out where
now it's like no i just want to go home
brian how do you feel about the comedy
store you miss it
um i do miss it and i've thought about
going back for like a week or so and
just hanging out and stuff but uh
i don't know it just it's it's it's so
weird there living in
austin it's really opened my eyes to
i don't know i don't feel like wearing
masks every time i go inside a
restaurant or a show
you know
being checked for
you know all this stuff just it seems
like it's not open yet it doesn't seem
like it's back to normal yet in los
angeles so i think i kind of don't want
to go now because i'm too scared that
i'm just going to be turned off by how
different it is so i don't know i mean
you myself
you myself joe the comedy store was a
big part of our lives and when us three
left like i thought about us
and how long we had been going down
there and what the store meant to us and
how much time we put down there i
thought we were gonna miss it a lot more
the thing with me was i went down there
with my wife and my daughter
and i basically just said goodbye from
the building i touched the building i
sat on the stairs
i went to all the places where i used to
smoke pot out there behind the van and
the back you know and uh i said my
goodbyes like i'm good with it i don't
know why
i feel a little shitty about it that i
feel good about it
but i don't know how i'm gonna suppose
how am i supposed to feel you know
i remember doug stanhope making fun of
me and joe like you guys will never
leave here because you'll never leave
the store
and i thought that was true and it's
true because without the store i can't
even do up
like the store was my
[__] anchor
and then from there i would develop and
go out into the road
ever since i stopped going to the store
that just took that out of my resume
like it was just so i wanted to see how
you were doing with it because you were
the captain of the [__] store the
party started when you got there
yeah i mean now the store i don't think
is open past 1am or midnight or
something like that i
i don't think the hangs there anymore
and and that's what i loved most about
the store is just hanging with all you
guys like hanging out in the back and
smoking some and you know and just
seeing every everybody around the store
and
from what i've been hearing it's not the
same like that anymore and that's that's
depressing to me so
i don't know i
i don't know if i could deal with that
it was weird because i never i thought
it was such a party when i was partying
like you were that was your last stop
every night like the store was it you
know like if you did new years at the
improv with joe
we'd always end up at the store to
[__] drink and jump up and down and
you know torture people and the whole
thing it's uh it's just mind-boggling to
me that after 23 years i just walked
away from the store
it really bothers me in a way but i've
learned to deal with it it's not like i
miss it
i see the lineups and i know that i
don't even know half the people
which lets me know how old i am
like i'm looking at stan i'm looking at
schedules from like
the place that's in new york city and
you know the really good comedy place
the seller
and i'm looking at the store lineups and
i'm seeing a 50 percent that i don't
even know these people
you know like i don't know taylor
tomlinson but i know she is
these people i've never even heard of
them
so how did they get to the store
like in that short a [__] period like
a year and a half and they became
regulars i don't even hear of these
people i've never even seen these
[__] people and i wish them all the
luck in the world i'm not hating on the
young generation i'm happy that people
are [__] still doing comedy and
they're in
but i just don't know where half of
these comedians came from it doesn't
bother me i don't give a [__] i'm just
saying that
wow in a year and a half comedy has
really passed me the [__] by and you're
the only guy that knew it you knew it
from the beginning like you're like i
don't think you're gonna get back on
stage
i don't feel it red band after not going
to the store that was everything to me
there's not even a club around here
there's great clubs uncle vinnie's is
great the stress factor is great
but they don't bring you the
satisfaction of the store
you know yeah that's one good thing that
i've been very happy about with austin
is that how many places there are to do
stand-up comedy like uh where
where all the clubs are there's
literally
10 clubs all around that you can just go
from spot to spot to spot kind of like
what i would imagine new york is
and
so many people have moved to austin from
the comedy store and all these comics
like derek poston assange dylan sullivan
tony hinchcliffe you know there's just
all these people
so it kind of feels like the old days of
the comedy store but now it's just in
austin it's it's it's definitely helped
to move uh to austin because it almost
feels normal just uh
the comedy scene here and it's just
growing and growing you know with rogan
opening his club i can't even imagine
how it's going to be in in a couple
months
it's a great scene it really really is
a great scene for young comics i think
right now
it's really and and when i say young
comics it could be a 40 year old that
just got into comedy
i'm talking about guys that have been
doing comedy from five to ten years
that's the point where there's no
[__] direction in comedy
you're not really a feature act yet
nobody's hiring you
you have the time but you know it's it's
really [__] up and it's great to be
in a
environment of your peer like that was
what was great about la for me when i
got to la i had josh wolfe
ralphie may was with us you know that
crew we were all young guys at that
point
you know we all went out to become
whatever we
became but we were all young guys brett
ernst you know i was a little older than
that crew brother and steve byrne
you know that that crew but it's great
that
i've always said man when you have a
good foundation of comedy you're gonna
springboard to do great things and
that's what's going on in austin right
now if you're a young comic i suggest
you go to austin and learn that's you're
not going to learn at the store anymore
it's not a
a school anymore you need help with that
you know mike and i were talking about
open mics for musicians
you know like they don't charge any
money you got to charge five dollars so
people are committed to it people won't
come if they see it something for free
they won't come
if they see five dollars or ten dollars
they'll go okay i might go because it's
it's worth the [__] uh party you know
whatever but that's honest to god i
think that's what i missed from stand-up
what we used to have when it was me you
joe ari
duncan on the road that was fun
then i started going on the road by
myself all the pressure was on me and i
had another guy helping me but it was
just two of us
you know it wasn't uh you know i would
sit in my room all day i'd see the i'd
see the feature act for lunch
maybe we'd go to uh something to look at
a [__] history something you know
hits town or something in detroit and
then you go back to your room it's not
like when we were [__] doing it we
would start at 11 in the morning go to
[__] papados
eat a meal to one go shoot guns
come back [__] go to the pool swim
so you're a comic all day and you're
with other comics and you're like-minded
and you're talking about the same [__]
then all of a sudden i started going on
the road selling tickets and i was by
myself
and it sucks dick
yeah yeah those were the days going to
papados and everything like that i went
to the papados that we used to go to
all the time with joe and ari and duncan
all the time i went there recently it
felt so weird being there that used to
be our go-to place every time we went
across from the doubletree yeah man that
doubletree that poor doubletree looks
like it needs to be torn down really
well you gotta remember like that was 20
years ago yeah that was 20 years ago
when that hotel was kicking and [__] the
last time i in fact the club doesn't
even when the club was still open
towards the end
they wouldn't even put you in that hotel
no more they used to put you at a
different hotel and i used to request it
no
put me at the doubletree well there's
nothing there [__] what do you mean
there's nothing there i'm walking
distance from [__] papados that's all
i need
that [__] banana pudding
with the vanilla wafers in it with the
little pieces of banana the [__]
seafood and crab salad i never finished
it i'm a fat [__] 380. and i can't
finish the [__] salad at papados the
shrimp were huge
they give you four huge [__] shrimp
and lump crab meat
with tomatoes lettuce onions i'd always
put blue cheese you know me [__] that
italian vinaigrette a little lemon
vinaigrette
i'm throwing some [__] blue cheese on
that [__] remember we used to have the
guy that used to give us tons of [__]
vikings and [__]
yeah he would pull up with a truck and
he used to just give his pills i bumped
into him by the show he's like you want
some pills i'm like [__] no i forgot
about that guy
remember he had a truck this
[__] had an electrical truck
and you like the little packages like
the little screws and [__] they were all
pills and then he's like i got weed too
you do and he would have drawers of
different wheat he was growing
hydroponic [__] weed it was wet and
[__]
nobody believed those [__] crazy road
stories where you got in trouble at the
strip club in austin
i had the yellow rose and what's so
funny is that the yellow rose uh is now
a sponsor of kill tony the whole like
the owners and everything they come to
every single show every monday and it's
just like old school family just like
the old days where like joe would be
doing a show and they would all send
like the limo to the show and you know
all the people they all come to it's
like it hasn't changed it's so good
there's a guy with the long hair that's
the guy that brought me to the yellow
rose
he looked like he did 20 years of
cocaine straight
he had wrinkles everywhere on his face
and long hair
he's around anymore no he's probably
good that guy old deed
10 years ago
that guy was in bad shape he reminded me
of the guy that used to sell us the
stars of death
that guy was in bad shape he only had a
few weeks left when he pulled out of the
start even lee was like why don't you
make me meet that creepy guy because i
don't want to meet the [__] guy
you go meet him
let him breathe on you and [__]
but no those were we had a great
upbringing with joe i'll never forget
that that was
one of my best educations the store was
a huge education and then going out with
him on the weekends getting lost
[__] doing 50 shots at uh
the brazilian place with the all you
could eat remember we did that look at
that child
focal the [__] child in dallas i mean
my roots go huge in texas
like i'm surprised i'm not in texas
because i love [__] everything about
texas the food
the mexican food the [__] way
everything about texas is [__]
tremendous i just it was time for me to
come home
you know i think we were all surprised
you didn't come to texas because
everybody was i mean texas was your
go-to place you know go to go to from el
paso to [__] houston to dallas i love
that addison improv i love that chuck
and jive
the restaurant the seafood restaurant
over there
i loved [__] houston you know that i
had deep
deep roots in houston best cocaine in 19
[__]
98 to 2007 they were the king all i had
to do was walk into houston and somebody
would give me a package i remember
somebody gave me a package once at the
[__] airport
that's when you know you're a junkie
when somebody comes up here at the
airport and says here's a package for
you and i opened it up with pete pete
was driving me back i opened it up there
was like a gram of coke in there it's
two in the afternoon i'm like i can't
[__] do this this will ruin
my goddamn day first time i went to
houston
first night
this is how can you not love a city that
offers this it's 1997 i don't have a
girlfriend
i go down there to open up for bobby
slate and i'm sitting at the bar i just
bombed i'm sitting at the bar and this
smoking colombian girl walks past me
with a white dude
and she's like don't look that bad you
were great don't worry about i'm like i
ate a bag of dicks
he went to the bathroom she came back
and she's like ah where are you from we
started talking
and i said you're colombian i need a big
favor i know you got a cousin or
somebody who sells coke in your [__]
family there's somebody somebody your
uncle your father
and she said how much coke do you wanna
go like a grandma blow and i gave her a
yard stick and she goes i'll call you in
a little while i had a pager then
she called me i go what do you want me
to meet you she goes no no no i'll bring
it back to the hotel i dump my date i'm
hanging with you
she came back with the grandma blow next
thing you know she had a bikini on at
that really good hotel in houston
the crazy one with the bar and [__]
where people were knocking on your door
and asked if they wanted a beer
people would knock on your door at that
hotel at two in the morning you'd be
like sitting there doing coke going i
wish i had a beer
and you're like what the [__] you open
the door it's like a chick hi
i had some extra beers i don't know if
you want to party no i'm just sitting
here by myself about to jerk off you
just knocked on the door you were my
[__] savior
then the hotel got flooded
oh yeah yeah that's the hotel that's
where
i think joe met his wife at that hotel
too that's a [__] great history hotel
they had a kalachi place down the corner
i don't know how many times i walked
like kalachi factory or
debuffs remember that the greek with the
melted cheese oh my god how many times
that old guy used to yell at people
he [__] used to just draw a menu at
you
you make you tell me when you want
something and then they would come back
i mean we went there one night we got a
bunch of greek food
i was farting for like a week i had
diarrhea they gave us like a cheesy
[__] thing with oh my god
that was that was
people would not believe the times we
had in texas were rogan from austin
i remember another time i was at that
old club this had to be 98
and i'm in the corner there watching joe
or somebody and some girl starts talking
to me and she's like look at my [__]
look at the hair what i did for the
design i'm like
i need this in my life next you know i'm
fingering i'm about to go on stage i go
on stage 10 minutes later i'm on the
stage and i can smell a little [__] on
my finger every time i talk to the stage
every time i talk to the audience on
mike
dawg and i used to bomb in austin
the biggest bombings i had were in
[__] austin dog because they were
like straight laced and [__] compared to
like houston and dallas that buck wild
but austin they were nice tight white
people they would hate me
and then i would take them for a
psychological ride and [__] and they
would enjoy me but it was rough but i
loved that so that club is closed
uh you're talking about cap city cap
city is closed and they're about to
reopen a new location but it's not the
it's not the old owners they i think
they're they're just reusing the name uh
so it's not going to be the same uh
people that used to own cap city uh but
they're they're yeah cap city's opening
up a new location and it should be open
any day now
i think about you every night
and then yesterday we spoke on the phone
we agreed to do the podcast and not 10
minutes after that
i get a [__] thing on facebook an old
picture you and me with a podcast
podcats
oh yeah podcasts we got to bring that
back long distance
podcats podcast i remember the song we
made cash cats
cat cat cats
kitty litter yeah we just talked about
cats and kitty litter and stuff now i
don't have any i haven't had cats in a
couple of a couple years do you have any
cats left i'm down to three
three cats and then there was three
[__] in fact friday when is the 17th
friday
friday is the anniversary of superbad
he's been dead for two years my little
[__] cat of love i'm down to three
cats two chubby ones super bad sisters
they're about ready to go my wife told
me that kid needs a gun they're peeing
weird and [__] oh no so one of them
takes a [__] the whole basement [__]
smells like a dead horse i gotta take it
outside and throw the neighbor's yard
every time he shits in my thing i take a
paper towel i take that [__] out of here
it's like a little thing it's like a
grenade of death
it just smells like bodies and puke and
[__] all rolled up into one [__]
piece of [__] i threw it in the
neighbor's yard i saw him like a week
later looking at it like what the [__]
because it stinks like death out there
then it shrinks up and it gets all
conglomerated but you have to cut it to
get the stink back
you break that piece of [__] in half and
the stink is back jack
yeah that's one thing i don't miss i
don't miss
litter boxes you know and i and dealing
with all that yeah i've had litter boxes
my whole life having cats and now i
don't have that anymore so it's so nice
not having that doug i had to clean
litter boxes
at the end of the month
my wife is leaving
so i'm home all alone and i was dreading
[__] clean little boxes and then our
friend joe rogan called me he's like you
want to do the podcast on those dates
so i got a girl to come in to [__]
clean the [__] thing thank god i hate
cleaning it but i do and you have to do
it in the morning
that's what sucks you have to wake up in
the morning
and you're not even awake yet and you
gotta scrape up this [__] and it smells
[__] horrible
and then you gotta i'm one of those
people i don't like you know you ever
see those people when they walk their
dogs they gotta walk down the block with
a little bag of [__]
listen to me i'd rather get raped in a
prison
by ten big black dudes that destroy my
[__] and [__] walk around you
would never see me walk around with a
bag with a piece of [__] that's why i
don't get a dog because i want to be
good to my society but
if i have a dog i'm not picking up dog
[__] that's where it's supposed to go
i'll take him to a field where nobody
walks and he could [__] up there but i'm
not picking up dog [__] walking down the
block the best is when those people stop
to talk to you
there's a lady who stopped saying how
are you i'm good a lot better than you
i'm not gonna have [__] in my hand go
home drop the [__] off then come back
and i'll talk to you all you want i'll
give you the history of cuba i'll give
you a little [__] one i'll give you
the history of my nutsack how bad it's
looking
my fungi toenail
yeah i'm not into it it sucks though
because we have two dogs and at least
they're they're small dogs so they're
very small poops
and uh
we we used to live when we lived in
burbank uh one time we forgot to get the
bring the bags you know so we're like
walking and it's like [__] and i'm like
looking around for a leaf or something
you know or something that and
we didn't have anything to do so we're
like all right i guess no one saw it no
no no crime you know
literally
the next day on that app next door you
know that afterwards the whole
neighborhood
literally there's video of us not
picking up our [__] and like 30 people
bitching about us not cleaning up the
poop you can't get away with anything
now because everyone has cameras on
their doors and crap like that so
that was embarrassing listen i don't
mind making the news
for saying something about somebody
but if i made the news for my dog not
picking from me not picking up my dog
[__] it wouldn't bother me whatsoever
what people have to say
you don't see me picking up dog [__] guy
that's that's all you need to [__]
you know
i don't want to pick up dog [__] my wife
my daughter keeps bugging me for a dog
and i'm like you're in no [__] danger
i go you want a dog wait till you move
out but i can't have a dog right now
because i'm gonna end up [__] walking
the guy
picking up his [__] and that's not gonna
[__] happen i don't wanna pick up dog
[__] in the yard not yet i'm not ready
for that i'm not old enough
well if you do get a dog don't get a big
dog because that's big poop you know
like
my shitzers are smaller than a cat so
when they poop it's like ah who cares
well what's a [__] small dog gonna do
for you what do i do put him in my purse
i'm gonna do put them in my [__] back
pocket i don't like [__] small dogs i
want a dog that listen i don't want a
violent dog but i want a dog that could
hold his own like if a dude breaks in
the dog will bite him in the leg or
something i don't want to [__] you
know
and that's what i'm scared of like my
daughter doesn't really like dogs she
likes dogs but she's scared of big dogs
but i showed her what a german shepherd
looks like and she's like i gotta live
with that so if she lets me get the
german shepherd i want one of those nazi
ones
that hates everybody jews spanish people
black people i don't give a [__] i want
a dog that just hates everybody
just walk i'm gonna get a female german
shepherd and not spare
not new to her so she gets horny you
gotta lock her up and she bleeds once a
month once a month you wake up and you
got 10 million little red spots around
here
because she's dripping that [__]
monkey juice from a dog on the carpet
it's a [__] nightmare my mom had a
dog that wasn't neutered the german
shepherd female she was [__] gorgeous
and that's why she you don't neuter them
they're [__] gorgeous and they act
different like you couldn't get next to
my mom's purse she would [__] bite
your head off
i could never clip a doll out of mom's
purse and [__] because of this dog
but the dog didn't bite constantly it
just bit you know when she was at the
bar and then we got rid of the dog bit
me
in the face and that was the end of that
[__] dog my mom got rid of that
yeah i uh i like i like joe has a cool
dog that golden retriever i've always
wanted a golden retriever
that's what i'm thinking i'm going to
get a chocolate retriever from my dog
yeah they're harmless they're fun they
run with you i wonder what happened to
his other [__] monster of a dog yeah
i've never asked i think he probably
just left him
yeah that dog was too [__] big he
started biting him as [__]
he started eating the eggs
joe was pissed when the [__] wolves
would eat his eggs and [__] when he had
the chicken coop and they would eat the
eggs i called them one day he's like
listen man i can't talk there right now
the [__] wolves got into the chicken
coop
and i got to beat chickens and [__] that
was the funniest conversation i had with
him this that day i talked to him this
morning so yeah
i'll be in austin in like two
[__] weeks jack
oh [__] yeah that's awesome
and then we're doing the
chrysler 500 episode podcast
where the [__] you going cocksuck i'm
talking to you
he's got to get his reefer he just did a
bong hit he's still hung over
[__] it the hair of the dog
i've always loved red band cause red
band is never [__] around red back
gets [__] up jack
redman gets [__] up early
what are you looking at
what what the [__] are you looking at on
that screen you haven't looked at me the
whole time you haven't seen how
beautiful i look
i know my
my my uh fan turned on so i had to turn
my fan off through the computer
like something happened with the
computer
but i still remember i got in trouble
with joe that night after the [__]
yellow rose
he called me the next one he's like you
get bang coke i'm like no yes you did
you lied to me
yeah that was so stupid of me i was in
the in the bathroom stall remember that
yeah but that's not stupid that's where
you did 90 of your cocaine
like right now people are getting pissed
off because ah i don't want my kid to
walk into a bathroom and there's a guy
with a skirt let me tell you something
i did more coke in a female bathroom
than anywhere else in my life whether it
was the belly room the belly room had a
female woman's bathroom have you ever
gone in there right there in that belly
room that's the best bathroom in the
[__] country to snort coke
they got a little table there you could
snort a line of coke then pick her up
put her on the thing and he's a [__]
monkey it's one stop shopping in there
the same you know
that's what you're supposed to snort
coke i remember one time i was snorting
coke in new york well not me i gave it
to a friend of mine i was with she went
in the bathroom she came out she was
like they got mad at me i was snorting
coconut i'm like it's 1993
1985 you could snort a kilo in there but
in 93 they were drinking water in new
york so it wasn't cool to do i don't
understand i did 90 of my coke i did in
the bathroom stall
yeah that was embarrassing getting
caught though the guy's like banging on
the door like hey get out you can't do
that in here
and you're like shut the [__] up
i'm not doing it
i'm not doing [__]
do you remember when the dude caught me
at the [__] uh that bar was where
jay davis used to do comedy
like that was the biggest shock in my
life
i'm down there doing coke with a girl
and he opens up the freezer and he's
like hey what are you doing i'm doing
coke close the freezer door why are you
[__] blocking he's like no i've
contacted the police you can't do that
i'm like dawg you didn't know about that
red man no
that [__] called the cops on me
was a little indian hindu dude he was in
charge of security and what was the name
of that bar did you ever get to go there
across from uh yeah it's across from
the pink taco now
yeah that was a [__]
dog and
from from 98 to 2005 or six
that place was amazing they didn't like
me they were into dane cook it's an
irish name right yeah so i only went
down there once two three times and then
i got banned
for that situation
you know i met a girl on the stairs it
was [__] mob we went to the freezer
to do coke the hindu came in he's like
what the [__] are you doing
and i'm like close the door we're doing
blow i don't want other people to see it
if you're in come in if you don't want
none then close the [__] door and he
goes no i called the cops i'm like what
do you mean to call the cops so then him
and three other bouncers came and took
me they didn't handcuff me or nothing
they took me and the girl outside and
they called the cops i had the eight
ball in my sock i'm like i'm not giving
this up this is a first time eight ball
and next thing you know [__] uh
they're like the cops are coming and i
look up and i see ralphie may because
across the street at that japanese place
tuesday nights was all you could eat
sushi so if you went there and did
comedy they'd give you all the sushi you
wanted [__] that's when britney
spears was going down there and whitney
houston with bobby brown they were
singing [__] and i will always love you
i never went in there i i don't know
anything about that place but ralphie
came and i go ralphie he goes i'm doing
a showcase for cbs player
i'm like what the [__] do you mean you
don't i go he goes what are you doing
out here this [__] calls the
cops on me
you got to get me out of here he's like
what do i do i go take that [__] car
turn it around and i'll jump in it
before the cops even see what the the
cops weren't there yet the girl was
crying
then joe and willie barcena came out joe
gave me a hundred dollars and said call
me when you get to the police station
you have cash i go no he gave me a 100
bill he goes call me when you get to the
police station i'll bail you out and joe
went inside and ralphie made a u-turn i
got in the [__] car with ralphie
and i was home by 8 30. i had an eight
ball 100 bill and i did a spot all by 8
30. i was ready to [__] go and then
like a week later i find that i've been
banned from the place oh no dublin and
it was me and the holtzman were banned
ask holtzman what he did i think
holtzman told somebody to go [__]
himself in there now was hostile still
in austin
no it was very weird holtzen you know he
he came to austin uh he still had his
place in la you know and then he was out
here for almost a year
and then
one day he just kind of didn't tell
anybody and drove back like a couple
weeks ago he just drove back and like i
was doing a podcast with him he didn't
say anything to me so i don't know if
something happened maybe something
happened back in l.a or what it's very
mysterious and i haven't called him yet
or anything i'm just kind of more in
shock
uh so i don't know if he's gone for good
or if he's just going back for the
holidays or something i have no idea
what's his where's who where is he
living
well he's had he's had a trailer he
lives has a trailer home uh in l.a that
he's had for like ever
and you know he has a girlfriend and all
that and
and uh so when he moved to austin i was
really surprised that he kept that
trailer and he came out by himself i was
like
all right so is he just living in you
know two different places at the same
time i don't know it's all very very
interesting he never he never really
he's a very personal or a private person
i guess and he never really opens up and
tells anyone what what's going on
very mysterio he probably has three
different whites you know so
he's a good dude i just
he's so funny austin loved him too like
everything he believed all the young
yeah all the young comics like looked up
to him he was getting you know in la he
was what getting up once or twice maybe
at the comedy store you know uh out here
he was getting up every night three
times a night headlining everywhere and
this is awesome to see holtzman you get
that much love
so i was surprised when when i saw him
that he might be moving back to l.a
yeah i just been seeing some pictures of
him and they're always at the comedy
story i'm like
what did he do you know what man he was
quiet for a long time
very funny and then
the documentary
gave him a little light and i got to be
honest here i was [__] happy as [__]
and so were a lot of other people
holtzman's loved you know hostman we all
sat back going when is holtzman gonna
blow the [__] up
holtzman was a perfect candidate to have
his show i mean for years they were
looking for uh
an archie bunker
fox was cbs was and i remember going to
a meeting once and i said i think you
guys should bring in brian holtzman
they didn't know who he was you know
like with your name on the [__] thing
every other couple nights i don't know
who you are
so when i saw he moved to austin and
everybody had embraced him i got to be
honest with you i was happy and i
thought that he was on his way so
whatever he decides to do i wish him
luck he's a [__] funny guy
you know he's one of those guys that if
he went on the road it would be a 50 50
every night
he would either bomb hard or [__]
take you to the next level you know
with his improvise and his little
material the way he presents it so
i wish him all luck in the world man hey
comedy's [__] hard
and people in my 30 years 29 years in
comedy people came and went you know
we're really happy that we stuck with it
i mean how long have you been doing it
for a night you've been involved with us
for 20 [__] years
yeah that's kind of honestly or not so
you've seen how hard it is you've seen
people come and go you saw a bunch of
[__]
come and go you know you started a bunch
of podcasts with people and people just
took off and whatever so
people gonna be people
you could help them for as long as you
want but you have to keep doing what you
do every [__] day you know and uh
that's basically it
i can't wait to come down and see you
[__] it's gonna be great
yes we gotta we got a lot of eating to
do really
yeah
there's one thing that i did not realize
is how much good food is out here in
austin i've always thought yeah barbecue
you of course you know texas has great
barbecue but maybe the best sushi i've
ever had is out here
like just
amazing restaurants out here everywhere
you go
some of the best deep dish pizza i just
found a new deep dish pizza by my house
that is all these guys from italy and
they have like this little place and
they just make these amazing deep-dish
pizzas it's crazy
and all this is in austin yeah
our friend owns this place called the
sushi bar and it's uh probably the best
sushi you'll ever have right
you gotta tell
we'll tell joe to try to get
reservations but uh it literally it's
like like a 15 16 piece meal like you'll
they'll they'll make it all in front of
you and then they'll put down like a
single plate in front of you and you eat
it you're like what and then the next
one they'll put another one down
and you just tell them when you want to
stop because they'll go for the whole
entire night and just make all these
insane things then there's one sushi
that they they drip bone marrow on the
top of it when it's i didn't give it to
you it's so crazy
i love all that craziness doug i love it
you missed burbank and you had a nice
little yeah and you know i did
uh but then burbank got really shady
near the end uh because i i moved out
here and then i had to go back for like
a week just to close out and clean my
old house out and give the keys back to
the person and you know when i first
landed and i started i picked up my
rental car i was like oh man this is sad
i you know i've lived here for 15 years
it's so sad to you know be back then
within like 24 hours there was like a
guy in my backyard like doing meth and
there was a tent down the street and
there was somebody getting robbed like
it was just
it was just not that
when i lived in burbank there was no
crime there was nothing that and then
covet hit it was a totally different
monster it was every day people's cars
getting broken into and my mail being
stolen off my front porch and just shady
people in your in your driveway you're
like what the [__] is this
it's really [__] sad what happened
there now i understood north and i said
it the other day on a podcast on my own
podcast
it was really sad what was going on and
i knew was something was changing
but i listen you know i was in burbank
every day either for alberto crane my
friend damon
i was always in burbank for flappers i
still remember doing 100 on magnolia
when i found out my wallet was lost
and i drove back at midnight and i made
that right um where flappers is
and right by where that [__] bar is
in the middle of the street where
everybody goes to my wallet was right
down the street folded on the street in
the middle i had walked across the
street and fell out of my sweatpants wow
and when i went back and found that wall
i'm like burgess burbank is the safest
place on the earth and what people don't
know is that disney pays security
to watch burbank and
burbank is very wired like it's this
hidden cameras everywhere because disney
wants to protect their investment
i never thought it would be bad in
burbank and i've seen what was happening
in sherman oaks
and in north hollywood and then one day
i drove to porto's you know during the
pandemic before i left i might as well
say
eat some cuban [__] potatoes and [__]
dog
when i got out of that car i saw people
jaywalking
and nobody jaywalks in burbank okay they
go to those two corners right there by
pornos
and when i saw him jaywalking there were
people that wouldn't be in burbank you
know who lives in burbank and no doesn't
live in burbank okay burbank is musty
and [__] you know
but when they walked when they got to
the other side i saw like a breeze come
in and the leaves
and i'm like that's a weird wind
like that's a weird wind and these guys
i guess burbank is done with and i'm
going to tell you something to help you
rest i spoke to damon last week i called
him to check up on him you know he said
to me it's funny you called he goes
today for the first time in my life i
thought about buying a gun
wow he goes people are walking into
people's houses in burbank
yeah and just somebody got killed that
lady's that lady got killed yeah
so it's really a shame i'm happy that
we're out of there i feel bad for the
people who are
sitting there
to advance their [__] careers you
know if you're single right now yeah i
would be in burbank or in la but with my
wife or your girlfriend who's a
sweetheart i wouldn't take a chance
because we got to answer for them you
know they're our wives they're our
girlfriends we gotta answer for them so
i wouldn't be in [__] l.a
so looking at that i mean they would
they're doing [__] dr uh what do you
call that house invasions
how's it going
from
melrose and [__] so
the the los angeles sheriff of the
uh lapd
uh recently put out a a thing saying
that he's right now not recommending
anyone visiting
tourists he can't protect them he says
yeah like the purge
and i'll tell you i'm surprised that new
york hasn't come out and said that
because
they're tourists built people come from
all over the world to see that christmas
light the ice skate you know to see
disney on ice whatever the [__] they do
in new york i don't want to go to new
york at all i i moved here i go to the
light every year to see the christmas
tree but the last two years i haven't
gone over that i don't go over there for
comedy i don't go over there you pay me
to shoot i'll go over there unless you
pay me [__] you pay me i'm not going
over that so
that's where i stand g money
but i'm happy you took the time today
red man i just wanted to see you i miss
you
you're my brother like i tell people all
the time when i die there's only gonna
be one [__] that cries and
that's red man
because you're the only [__] who
loved me so i'm happy you took the time
today
i'm excited about being going down there
too bad you didn't make eye contact with
me you must be high on powders or
something
watch make eye contact with me
my camera is over here
see my camera's here and my screen is
down here you look like me when i was
doing coke i wouldn't make eye contact
with nobody i always be looking at the
bird over there on the shelf but there
was no [__] bird
you look good brother if i look at the
camera then i'm then i i can't see you
you're down here the camera's up here
all right well whatever you want to look
i love you red band i'm happy you took
your time today brother thank you very
much i know you hung over
and i want to congratulate you on what
you're doing down there and i'll be at
the vulcan on a monday night to torture
you a little bit [__] yeah so stay black
all right say hello to everybody for me
tell tony to
clean this [__] cowboy hat uncle
joey's coming down here
he doesn't think i saw those pictures
with him trying to be [__] john
cougar mellencamp
that's his new look man he has more
accessories oh my god he's got shirts
and buttons he's chewing a toothpick now
his name is bubba
i love you brother merry christmas to
you and your family are you going to
columbus at all
probably uh well i'm booking i just
booked the funny bone so i'm going to be
there in a couple months probably i just
got to pick a date but uh i'm married to
a little tour so probably in in the in
the spring
all right stay black all right thank you
see you in a few weeks love you love you
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed red band i hope you enjoyed
me today we had a great [__] little
tata like i said i'm gonna be in austin
in a few weeks i'm doing joe's podcast
for all you [__] that keep
telling me i had a dream you on joe's
podcast it's not a dream no more it's a
[__] reality we'll go talk about the
last year and what's going up for the
future and that's it and that's that i
love you [__] with all my
goddamn art
i'm happy you're still supporting and i
love you for it thank you very much for
having my back
the joey diaz [__] project will be up
friday on patreon
and uh we'll be back monday morning tip
top magoo i love your [__] suckers with
all my heart and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors
aight
i want to thank
red band but most importantly i want to
thank you [__] savages for always
having my back the joint is brought to
you by stamps.com listen if you're going
to the post office this time of the year
you're in for a rude awakening long
lines stinky people
you know people don't know what the [__]
they want forget about it stamps.com can
help you mail everything
from the [__] warmth of your own
house listen we've been with stamps.com
for close to 10 years tremendous
it helps us out dramatically my wife
loves it she puts the package you call
the post office they come they pick up
the boxes it's that easy you could print
official postage for any letter package
any way you want to ship
going to the post office instead of
using stamps.com you're wasting your
time guys why would you do that with
stamps.com you get exclusive discounts
on postage and shipping from usps and
ups once your mail is ready just
schedule a pickup or drop it off no more
traffic no more lines take the confusion
out of shipping
if you're not with stamps.com
you're slipping do me a favor this is a
free [__] offer sign up with promo
code joey j-o-e-y
joey free for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
and a digital scale you can't beat that
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code joey with stamps.com you'll
never go to the office again i want to
thank stepstamps.com
sponsoring the podcast they're great
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
line i love cbd line
i've been using them for [__] three
years and i can't get enough of them
every day i have a different use for a
different
product that they have whether it's the
cream
whether it's the
bath balls whether it's the lotion
whether it's the tincture
you could smoke it the gummy bears are
tremendous they have melatonin in them
and cbd i mean come on cbd line is
number one they're vegan
uh organic gummy bears the raspberry
will [__]
make your eyes pop out of your head so
do me a favor go to cbdline.com read
read what they have available to you and
for you and how it can help you
they'll help you to get the exact cbd
for what you need so go to cbd lion
press in joey
church joint and get 20 off delivered
right to your house cbd lion
the best in cbd oh the joint is also
brought to you by manscape listen i
don't know how long i've been talking to
you about manscape the ceramic tile will
not nick your ball sacks you could shave
your chest you could all the whole body
it works on the performance package and
manscape is tremendous it starts with
the performance package 4.0
and the lawnmower body trimmer listen
this is the best trimmer on the market
for your balls
butt and your body and now you'll also
get the weed whacker which helps you
clean out your ears and your [__]
nose disgusting plus all the old snots i
found the snot in my nose when i was
weed whacking that a [__] could hold
on from that's how [__] strong and
long it was but wait there's more
with the perfect package they're going
to throw in the crop preserver and the
crop reviver ball toner plus manscape's
anti-shaving boxes and a beautiful
leather travel bag with an inside zipper
you can hide whatever you want but you
didn't hear it here and now you can pair
that with the manscape's new body wash
with aloe vera and sea salt just in time
for the holidays they got doing one
shampoo and a conditioner this whole
package works from your head to your
[__] stinky balls that's why they
call it the perfect [__] package your
balls are gonna shine so [__] much
[__] rudolph is gonna be embarrassed
so do me a favor
right now get twenty percent off this is
a perfect christmas gift twenty percent
off referral free worldwide shipping at
manscape.com
again that's 20 off and free worldwide
shipping at manscape.com
joey be the ballsiest
ballgiver out there this year with
manscape i want to thank manscape
i want to thank stamps.com i want to
thank cbd lion
on it
i want to thank me undies and better
help therapy online therapy
they're [__] great companies to be
with i love you guys i'll see you monday
morning
tip top magoo ready to stab three
[__]
stay black
well this is a magic [__] candle love
you
foreign
[Music]
so
you